hello rejects right outside my window
is thus true the main busy street I live
on where a car alarm right outside my
window was going off and it still goes
off about every 10 to 15 minutes when I
was reaching like 7 a.m. I was like you
know what Wonder Woman trailer supposed
to drop
maybe I'll just pull an all-nighter and
wait for it to drop I end up like
falling asleep without realizing I'm
falling asleep and then I wake up
because because the car alarm wakes me
up again so if you hear this car alarm
go off in the middle of the video
there's some [ __ ] or [ __ ] that just
not bother to [ __ ] deal with their
car alarm that has just kept me up I got
like an hour asleep but we're here we're
here to watch the one who haven't
trailer let's get to it
The Da Vinci Code used to want to save
the world
[Music]
Bewdley
Wow this beautiful Steve Trevor
but the closer you get the more you see
the great darkness within
damn
whoa oh no neven card way a long long
time ago
[Music]
what is your mission to stop the war
what war the war to end all wars
weapons for other than you can ever
imagine Psycho Mantis can be ours
you are you are in more danger than you
think cannot stand by while innocent
lives are lost
be careful Diana
who's this woman she's my secretary sir
she's a very good secretary nice
which is our sacred duty to defend the
world and it's what I'm going to do
Wonder Woman
damn some really good-looking visuals
here Wow
[Music]
you
[Music]
parson is fighting this fight we use our
principles although I am not opposed to
engaging in a bitter fisticuffs should
the occasion arise haha she's probably
gonna be my favorite character she's
[ __ ] hysterical well that was a
really cool trailer that was pretty
sweet but my first impression is that DC
is whiny give us a trailer that doesn't
seem like it's trying too hard now look
at because I remember we got like those
Baptists VBS trailers in the second
trailer really upset a lot of people
then we got the Suicide Squad trailer
which is just the [ __ ] ton of fun this
seems to have like a mix of a good dark
film but with sprinkles of humor
throughout especially with Steve
Trevor's character I'm really looking
forward to this movie because it's
co-written by Geoff Johns who's the
creator of the flash TV series and that
show is exceptionally well done I know
there's flaws whatever but I still think
it's a fantastic show I'm already really
sold on that and when patty Jenkins was
working on this movie one thing she said
that she kept asking herself like for a
lot of the shots for a lot of the style
for most of these scenes even scenes
that didn't really have action just like
cool looking scenes she wanted to she
kept asking herself what does she view
as bad as what does she look as to be
something that's badass in terms of
female perspective and there's a lot of
badassery in this [ __ ] trailer I mean
this seems to be their most beautifully
shot film thus far out of the DC EU I
love the landscape of where the
Amazonians live it's it looks so [ __ ]
beautiful it looks like a beautiful
Island to be a part of I love the
costume designs the Amazonians like
their outfits they're they're sexy
outfits but they're also like still seem
like yeah you could totally be a warrior
and fight with this [ __ ] like it's a
good cross between sexy female presence
with you know good gear to rock when
you're actually fighting there's just
some really cool visual shots I love
that moment
where that one woman jumps off and she's
like hanging by that I'm sorry my words
are just so bad right now
but she's like swinging by she's
shooting her arrow and then that soldier
shoots at her and like the way that
whole sequence was done I'm sure it's
gonna play out a little bit longer in
the actual film just off the trailer
here it looked really [ __ ] sweet I
don't know the proper the proper
technical word doesn't come to mind here
but I really like the blue kind of look
that the cinematography has on the film
it has sort of like a blue kind of color
palette if you look at a lot of the
scenes especially the scenes where she's
actually in you know like America or
fighting in the war it really does have
like a blue look to it which kind of it
seems a little reminiscent of Captain
America the First Avenger but I don't
feel like I'm watching Captain America
the First Avenger when I watch this
trailer in terms of finding a good
balance with tone and humor like
bouncing dark and serious stuff with
some nice humor I feel like a lot of
that's really gonna come through with
Chris Pines character Steve Trevor and
because he just seems like a really
funny guy I mean he's hilarious is Kurt
he's pretty funny in a lot of movies
actually Chris Pine is great with comedy
and I feel like the interaction he will
have with Wonder Woman will probably be
something that really adds a kind of
personality to it cuz the Amazonian
woman seemed like this seems they showed
here they say they're very serious
people they seem like people you just
don't [ __ ] with him and I got a really
serious situation here at hand so make
sense why you don't really see them
cracking jokes in this trailer but but
with Chris Pine Steve Trevor I saw the
Wonder Woman DC animated cartoon the one
that came out a couple of years ago and
that was a really cool cartoon and it's
cool seeing it like really brought to
life I never read the comics so it's
cool seeing like these from just
watching that and then watching this
whoa it's really ear and patty Jenkins
man I don't know if anything she's done
where she's really done so much action
but she looks like she really captured
the action sequences well here I like
what they're doing with the slow-mo use
here and we need it sometimes I'm like
I'm wondering is it gonna be a little
too much of Diana does a cool kick and
they were flying through the air and
they're doing in slow-mo or she's
breaking through glass or something
but it kind of it does seem like it's
adding that impact and it does have like
that cool visual sense it does remind me
like fight scenes from like 300 zack
snyder's 300 so even though I know it's
on his film I'm sure he probably played
some kind of a tour inspiration on it in
terms of the DCE
films this looks like this could be its
tightest film I mean that the story of
the trailer is very well communicated
there's a war going on Diane as it were
like they live on that island and she
wants to help out and she's probably
gonna this is how we're gonna discuss
this is gonna be her origin story of how
she became Wonder Woman them hero we all
got to know the plot seems easy to
follow and it doesn't seem like it's
gonna be all over the place like this
seems like this could be a very
well-structured film I know there was
that letter from a Warner Brothers
employee that got out where she was
talking about don't even get me started
on all the [ __ ] we heard about Wonder
Woman behind the scenes I don't know I
still put on awesome isn't for these
films like I haven't given any of the
recent installments the greatest
feedback from in my personal opinion but
they make great trailers and this
trailer was really well done because I
really feel that we got a sense for
scenes like actual scenes that play out
that aren't just edited like a music
video and there seems to be a good build
of character that's going to happen
throughout there seems are going to be a
nice touch of personality the action
sequences look great and unlike the
other ones I think the biggest thing I
take away from this trailer is how I
really feel that there's a sense of
heroism here that I really feel that
we're gonna like be in the audience like
yeah Diana rising to become Wonder Woman
like to become that hero because I know
she she was talking to an interview
about how BBS you know it's 80 years
after this so she's a lot more wise
that's a lot more experience understands
the world a lot more here she's kind of
has more of an ego a little bit more
naive I know gal gadot was talking in an
interview about how
a woman is supposed to be a little bit
more egotistical a bit more naive
because BBS was 80 years after all this
happened in BV ashes someone has a lot
more experience she's someone who's a
lot more wise you really do get a sense
for a definitive character art that's
going to happen here where she really
does learn to become a wise hero and you
really feel like these are going to be
experiences that affect and cause her
character to really grow so this seems
like this could be its most tightly
woven film I'm really hopeful is that
I'm really hoping that because all the
trailers Raviv yes like like two of them
at least like got me really pump it
Suicide Squad trailer is gonna be really
excited I'm hoping this is great you
know Geoff Johns involved in this how it
gives me a lot of hope this trailer
looks really cool I love that the action
scenes seem very stylistic there seems
like there's going to be a lot of
standout action sequences and you could
really see the action which I appreciate
like it doesn't look like chaos
especially for uh action scenes in a war
movie like pretty neat and I really feel
like this will be that first DC EU film
where were like yes the same way help
the flash show makes you feel like flash
is a hero I didn't really get that sense
in with anyone in BBS or even Man of
Steel even though I like Man of Steel
but with this one I really feel we're
gonna get that which gets me excited and
shout out to William Stryker remember
he's in the trailer I rejects via the
channel subscribe to do dirt accepted